oh my god you guys are still talking
about spider-man well they keep
revealing stuff about spider-man all
right guys so we got two things we got
to talk about today first thing on the
list tom holland wants the amazing
spider-man 3. talked about why we're
gonna go into the video itself in a
second and then the other thing is both
him and charlie cox spoke about this tom
holland spoke about wanting a daredevil
spider-man team-up movie i also want to
kind of go into which comic i'd like
them to specifically adapt as well or at
least draw inspiration from i feel like
it would line up the best with the mcu
with that being said let's uh hit that
like button if you haven't done it so
whip it and now let's uh let's go into
this
[Music]
all right so first thing on the list
here we got uh tom holland talking with
brandon davis from comicbook.com the
legendary man brandon davis he is and
here's where he asks him about the
amazing spider-man 3 have you seen this
this clip in here yeah no are you one of
us who also want to see the amazing
spider-man 3 with andrea returning i
would love to see the amazing spider-man
3 i think what was so wonderful was how
andrew was able to kind of make amends
with the character in the studio you
know uh to kind of win the general
public back uh that scene where he saved
zendaya like the fan reactions in the
theater were so
spectacular so should sony decide to do
that they would have my full support and
obviously so would andrew i mean it just
makes a big difference to me because
obviously we've talked extensively about
what the amazing spider-man 3 could
ultimately be we even did a video not
long ago about every clue in easter egg
that morbius and venom are in the andrew
garfield spider-man universe it's like
with tom holland going out there and
showing his support for it that just
gives it an extra push that it actually
seems like it's a real possibility
giving the you know like the stamp of
approval like please go ahead and do it
makes it feel like even more like it
could actually come to fruition oh yeah
especially in a post-snyder cut world
and in a world now where all the doors
are off and everyone's got a multiverse
seems more possible than ever and i
think that there are more than enough
clues to indicate that it is likely to
happen maybe some sprinkling some andrew
garfield in and some of the other sony
stuff and at least and building up to it
yeah i heard one theory going around
that maybe the reason why dayton de
haan's green goblin doesn't appear or
wasn't even mentioned in spiderman no
way home is because when he talks about
how he let his rage get the best of him
in no way home then maybe he actually
killed
one dana hans green goblin that's that's
a quite a grip
but i could i could imagine it and that
would be a fascinating thing to watch
that character deal with the aftermath
of all right guys well yeah now that we
got that out of the way i hope that tom
holland's endorsement allows us to
happen let's talk about some daredevil
news recently we had tom holland in the
media he said this when talking about
spider-man no way home and daredevil he
said it obviously teased the future of
what could be i hope that one day we
find a way for spider-man and daredevil
to team up again and then charlie cox
was actually recently asked about this
uh have you seen this yet i have not
this is all news to me all right then
i'm going to play this here and it's
only like a minute long of charlie cox
talking about this and this is the stuff
i'm most excited about i mean i i i
i feel so lucky to have been cast in
that role and it and it is the gift that
keeps on giving i loved every single
minute making the show
but so to be honest to come back um and
to be involved in any capacity is
absolutely thrilling to me and i hope
you know i don't want to sound greedy
but i hope i get to do loads more i hope
i get to be involved way way more for
many years i hope it never ends i hope i
hope it gets a point where people are
like you're too old to be playing this
part
never kiana reeves it look and i i don't
know what their plans are but yes my
hope is that i get to do as much as much
as i as i'm allowed to do and to be
involved and and you know be really fun
the one thing that being in the mcu
allows that we couldn't really do in the
with the netflix stuff
is that i can now interact with other
mcu yeah right you can um
so i'd like that would be really cool
crossovers would be really is the thing
i would like to do next i don't know
what it looks like and i don't know what
you know what they're planning and all
that kind of stuff but
you know that that's
there are some really interesting
stories there that i would like to i'd
love for the character to explore well i
realized i just downloaded this clip but
i didn't actually watch it how did you
hear me if i've seen it have you seen
this i mean him talking about that
brings up such great points it's like
charlie cox was only able to interact
with pretty much whatever netflix
characters he was allowed to interact
with you know in the comics especially
daredevil and spider-man have teamed up
like many times part of the excitement
of seeing daredevil representing peter
parker in no way home which is something
that's happened in comics before where
matt murdock has represented peter
parker i would absolutely love for him
to keep on going i mean we're hearing
rumors about him possibly appearing in
echo you know we're also hearing rumors
about kingpin be touted up as one of
like the the next big villains of the
street level side of the mcu perhaps for
turning in the echo series what i've
kind of been hoping for personally is
that in the 90s there was this comic run
i believe it's called spider-man kingpin
to the death in that comic book
basically there's someone is like
dressed up as spider-man and they're you
know committing crimes that are making
it seem like spider-man's doing it
daredevil doesn't believe it's him
daredevil and spider-man they end up
working together and they uncover that
the man behind this plan is actually
kingpin wilson fisk with the fact that
we have kingpin reintroduced in hawkeye
and then presumably will come back in
the echo series no no that's confirmed
that's just a major speculation but
let's assume he is and then if we could
start building up kingpin in the new
spider-man trilogy with tom holland
where now this new peter parker the one
that where everyone's forgotten who
peter parker is he's more street level
so you could start building up kingpin
so what if we can get to a part three of
the new trilogy where then you have you
know a team-up movie where you have
daredevils arch nemesis that has
established in the netflix series and
then you have spider-man's new nemesis
as established in the new trilogy and
they have to team up together to take
him down i think that would be like the
perfect team-up movie especially for you
know charlie cox and spider-man i think
people really want to see specifically
daredevil and spider-man work side by
side oh yeah and plus you would get the
added bonus of having them meet all over
again given the spell and the way things
end in spider-man no way home like they
would get to forge a whole new
relationship after that then you could
watch them you know as you saw them in
the legal setting for a second and now
you get to see them out in the street
getting physical and fighting crime and
i think that would be a really fun way
to yeah pay homage to what's come before
but also start completely fresh well
there's a comic book too i don't
remember the name of it but it's one of
the ones when spider-man does have the
uh symbiote suit he's like becoming a
little bit more unhinged and violent and
daredevil's trying to like reel him in
kind of of that provocation what i'm
thinking that they could do is sort of
draw some inspiration from that that if
he might think that spider-man is
actually the one committing these crimes
and he's trying to take him down and
then perhaps going off of what they do
with no way home he could be like look
here's who i am you got to try to
remember me you actually helped me once
you know
so i think that way you like tie this
all together in that regard too would be
a pretty neat way of handling it and a
great way to take out that first piece
of unraveling the spell without going
straight to ned and mj yeah yeah to try
that i mean if you were to do something
where it's like you know me we've met
you know come on and like you know
realize it so i think there's a lot of
really exciting things we got the madame
webb in store right now obviously tom
hall will be coming back despite
whatever [ __ ] he's saying he's coming
back and then i think with this
multiverse established you could totally
have your andrew garfield universe
running simultaneously tom holland's
endorsing it they're basically all
endorsing the spider-verse so let's keep
this train going guys what do you think
about this do you want daredevil and
spiderman to team up do i need to ask
you this question
leave a like we will catch you guys soon